Our genetic information, our
DNA, is conveniently packaged
into little bundles called
chromosomes.
Humans have 23 pairs of
them, 46 altogether.
They contain the instructions
that the body uses to build
itself, the recipe for
a human, if you will.
Accidentally duplicating copies
of the DNA instructions
can cause problems later on.
That's what happens in Down's
syndrome, a genetic condition
that causes developmental and
physical disabilities.
It's a result of accidentally
inheriting additional copies
of some of the DNA
instructions.
Down's patients typically have
an extra chromosome 21.
So instead of 46 chromosomes,
they have 47.
Where does this extra chromosome
come from?
It happens during the formation
of sperm and eggs, a
process called meiosis.
During meiosis, your 46
chromosomes are shared out so
that only half of them, 23, go
into each sperm or egg cell.
I'll show you using just one
of the sets of chromosomes,
although actually it's
happening to all
23 at the same time.
Now originally, one of
the pair will have
come from your father.
Let's say it's this blue one.
And the other one will
have originally
come from your mother.
Let's say it's this red one.
First of all, each chromosome
makes a copy of itself.
It duplicates, making four
altogether, two stuck together
from the father and two stuck
together from the mother.
These then move to the middle of
the cell, where they match
up and almost wrap around
each other.
It's then that something called
crossing over occurs,
where genetic material is
exchanged between chromosomes.
This mixing process
can generate new
combinations of genes.
It's one of the most vital
features of sexual
reproduction.
Now the chromosomes are pulled
in opposite directions by
fibres that come from the
sides of the cells.
They're pulled apart once
and then once again.
And the four separate
chromosomes go into four
separate sex cells.
Remember, this is actually
happening with 23
pairs, not just 1.
And so each sex cell ends
up with 23 chromosomes.
In males, those all go on
to become sperm cells.
In females, it's slightly
different.
Only one of them goes on
to become an egg cell.
During fertilisation, you get 23
from the male sperm and 23
from the female egg, making 46
in total again, 23 pairs.
Down's syndrome occurs when
during this pulling apart
process of meiosis something
goes wrong with
chromosome number 21.
Instead of the four chromosomes
separating and
being pulled apart, at some
point two of them go together.
And both go into one sex cell.
During fertilisation that sex
cell fuses with another one to
form an embryo.
It means that there are three
copies of chromosome 21,
rather than the usual two.
In total, the embryo
has 47 chromosomes.
Chromosome 21 being the shortest
human chromosome, the
foetus can normally survive.
If this sort of thing happens to
other chromosomes with more
genetic information, the outcome
is usually fatal.
The intricate mechanics of how
our sex cells are created can
make the difference between
life or death.